eso
[Música]
si sumamos todo lo que las familias
peruanas gastan en un año nos daríamos
cuenta que ese monto podría superar los
250 mil millones de soles al año pero
eso no es lo sorprendente lo
sorprendente es que hay una parte de la
población que es la responsable por el
73% de todos esos gastos quieren saber
quiénes son
voy a contarle la historia de beto y de
soya ellos están incluidos en esta parte
de la población
betis hoy las son una pareja de la selva
que vinieron a la capital con el sueño
de una vida mejor
ninguno de los dos concluyó sus estudios
pues ve todo desde muy joven ayuda a sus
padres la chacra y zoila quedó
embarazada de su hijo mayor
cuando llegaron les fue bastante difícil
había días en que no tenían ni para
comer se refugiaban y trabajaban en lo
que hubiese con tal de llevar un pan
para la casa hasta que un día la hermana
de beto les ofreció prestarles dinero
para poder comprar una carretilla y
dedicarse a la venta ambulante de frutas
fue así como ellos empezaron a avanzar a
prosperar trabajaban de sol a sol y con
el dinero ganado pasaron de vivir en
esteras a construir parte de su vivienda
de material noble aunque bueno el baño
todavía no está terminado y el agua la
siguen recibiendo por un caño en la
parte exterior de la vivienda
pero pasaron de comer casi únicamente
arroz papá a veces huevos e incluir
pollo y más variedad en su alimentación
pasaron de creer que a todos sus hijos
no les quedaba de otra que dedicarse al
refugio y a la venta ambulante a pensar
que al menos uno podría estudiar y ser
profesional
sin duda hoy día ayer tienen una vida
mejor de la que tenían cuando llegaron a
la capital no obstante sus necesidades
básicas no están completamente cubiertas
o la forma de cubrirlas es ineficiente
en muy precaria
así como beto isolda el 87% de la
población pertenece a la base de la
pirámide me refiero a familias de
niveles socioeconómicos c d y e que son
la mayoría del país ellos son los que
mueven la economía del perú son los que
hacen líderes a las marcas incluso los
que eligen presidentes este 87% es
responsable por el 73% de todas las
compras pagos y gastos que hacen las
familias y así como ves eso y la la base
de la pirámide día a día se enfrenta a
una serie de desafíos
73 por ciento de la fuerza laboral en el
perú es informal 70% no está afiliado a
ningún sistema de pensiones esto quiere
decir que cuando envejezcan y no puedan
trabajar no van a contar con un fondo
con un dinero para vivir
sólo tres de cada diez peruanos está
debidamente bancarizado y esto limita su
crecimiento ya que siempre van a
depender de la capacidad financiera de
un familiar de un amigo de que los pueda
ayudar pero no de ellos mismos
49% de los adultos no terminó la
secundaria y sólo dos de cada diez
estudiantes de secundaria entienden lo
que lee esto les impide acceder a
empleos de calidad pero además los
limitan la gestión de un negocio propio
75 por ciento de las viviendas en el
perú son producto de la autoconstrucción
levantados con mano de obra informal no
calificada este tipo de construcción
además de ser inseguro es caro es sobre
el poco costo podría alcanzar hasta el
40 por ciento
y los servicios básicos no son tan
básicos solo 56 por ciento de las
viviendas reciben agua todos los días el
resto está muy vulnerable a contraer
enfermedades
y para qué vamos a hablar del sistema de
salud cierto hoy día todos hemos sido
testigos de un sistema de salud que es
excluyente que es deficiente que es muy
frágil hasta el año pasado uno de cada
cuatro peruanos no contaba con ningún
tipo de seguro de salud ni público ni
privado esto hacía que si se enfermaban
no hay dónde tener donde atenderse hoy
van a tener que hacerlo de manera
particular y pagar ese costo y va a ser
bastante difícil
este grupo mayoritario además de tener
ingresos limitados y necesidades aún
insatisfechas terminan pagando más caro
por los productos y los servicios que
las clases altas a esto se le llama
penalidad de la pobreza
sabían ustedes que los cerros de lima se
pagan hasta 37 veces más por el agua que
en un distrito de clase alta o que un
producto tan básico como el arroz puede
llegar a costar 30 por ciento más
la penalidad de la pobreza se
materializa cuando la logística pensada
desde su forma habitual es mucho más
caro llegar a un lugar más distante el
producto pasa por muchas manos antes de
llegar a la bodega de la señora flor
penalidad de la pobreza se materializa
cuando la señora teresa tiene que tomar
una mototaxi una combi para ir a la
agencia más cercana a pagar su cuenta de
luz y esto la obliga a dejar de ganar
por el lavado de ropa que le hace a su
vecinita porque entre ir y venir se le
fue la mañana penalidad de la pobreza se
materializa cuando rosa accede a
préstamos con altos intereses porque no
le puede mostrar al banco que ya sí es
una buena pagadora y que cumple con sus
compromisos porque no tiene un historial
crediticio porque no tiene una boleta de
pago que diga lo que ella gana porque
los cachorros que ya hace no cuentan
porque tampoco tiene un amigo un
familiar que sirva de aval porque en su
red están todos en las mismas
condiciones
penalidad de la pobreza
pese a esto las familias de la base de
la pirámide con fe con optimismo con
trabajo duro y resiliencia consiguen
articular estrategias de sobrevivencia
para poder avanzar y crecer
entonces si son tan importantes para
nuestra economía y para nuestro país y
tienen esa capacidad de salir adelante y
hacer frente a la adversidad cómo
podemos hacer para que vetó soy la flor
theresa rosa pasan de sobrevivir a
prosperar
desde muy joven he tenido contacto con
la pobreza
he estado en comunidades rurales al sur
de chile ayudando a las familias en sus
actividades productivas cosechando papas
maíz ayudándolos a construir sus casas
pero sobre todo conociendo los
entendiendo lo que era realmente
importante para ellos y aprendiendo y
mucho de la forma como ellos hacían para
resolver sus problemas
cuando elegí mi carrera me fui por los
negocios y por el marketing y hasta ahí
yo veía un claro divorcio entre el mundo
de los negocios y el mundo de lo social
no fue sino hasta el 2003 en brasil en
mi escuela de vida que fue la consultora
data popular que descubrí que los
negocios podían ser agentes de cambio y
transformación para reducir la
desigualdad e incluir alusiones de
personas desde ese entonces conocer a la
base de la pirámide ha sido parte de mi
propósito conocerla desde diferentes
países latinoamericanos lo que me ha
permitido encontrar patrones de
comportamiento que se repiten y que son
consistentes independientemente del país
en donde están y que me ha ayudado a
desarrollar negocios con impacto
negocios inclusivos
los negocios inclusivos son una
iniciativa empresarial que busca incluir
hacer parte a la base de la pirámide de
un negocio ya sea como consumidores
dándoles acceso a productos y servicios
que realmente mejoren su calidad de vida
como proveedores capacitándolos y
comprando les a precio justo el insumo
que ellos producen como distribuidores
desarrollando sus habilidades
ayudándolos a tejer sus redes para que
puedan generar sus propios ingresos o
como colaboradora en una empresa para
que puedan crecer y tener un futuro
mejor
esta forma de ver los negocios está
sostenida en una relación ganar-ganar
donde ambas partes ven claramente el
beneficio
clara las empresas porque al entender lo
que la base de la pirámide realmente
necesita son capaces de generar una
propuesta de alto valor que puede llegar
a muchísimas personas apostando por
negocios de volumen y de escala que sí
que pueden ser rentables y ganar la base
ya que mejora su calidad de vida como
consumidor al tener un producto que
realmente atienda a sus necesidades o
aumentan sus ingresos como proveedor
distribuidor o colaborador todos ganan
en el caso de al grano una empresa
chilena que se dio cuenta que la familia
de la base de la pirámide al tener
ingresos diarios compraban de a poquito
en envases pequeños como sánchez y
terminaban pagando mucho más caro por
esa compra ya que pagaban por el
producto pero también por el empaque
al gramo vio que ahí había una
oportunidad para generar una eficiencia
y reducir los costos y comenzó a vender
productos de primera necesidad como
arroz o menestra en envases
reutilizables de esta forma las familias
compraban los productos los llevaban a
casa y una vez se terminaban podían ir a
la bodega más cercana y rellenarlo en
máquinas dispensadoras de esta forma las
familias ya no tenían que pagar por el
empaque y redujeron sus costos hasta en
un 40% además colocaron menos plástico
en circulación
hoy el gran cuenta con 2500 bodegueros
afiliados y está expandiendo su modelo
de negocio a otras ciudades y otros
países del mundo
se imaginan el universo de oportunidades
que se abre si diseñamos productos y
servicios para la base de la pirámide
sobre todo en el momento de crisis en el
que estamos apostando por negocios de
volumen y de escala se imagina
he pasado más de 15 años de mi vida
conociendo a la base de la pirámide y
desarrollando un modelo de negocios
inclusivos que me han demostrado que sí
que es posible que tanto la base como
las empresas tengan una relación
ganar-ganar
en el caso de ortiz luz pero una empresa
agroindustrial dedicada principalmente
al cultivo de berries todos los años las
empresas agrícolas necesitan contratar a
muchos colaboradores durante la época de
cosecha
pero no sólo eso necesitan que sus
colaboradores se queden con ellos
durante toda la campaña y esto es todo
un reto porque los colaboradores suelen
pasar de una empresa a otra conforme a
los beneficios que se les ofrece
hortifrut quería entender que podían
hacer para que sus colaboradores se
quedaran con ellos durante toda la
campaña fue así como fuimos a entender
el mundo de los colaboradores agrícolas
fuimos a conocer cómo vivían a qué
desafíos se enfrentaban así como cuál
eran sus sueños y sus aspiraciones
fue en esta vivencia que conocimos a
apóstol que refleja la historia de vida
de miles de colaboradores agrícolas en
el perú
apóstol hace unos 20 años se hacen todo
en una zona de agroindustrial al norte
del país una zona que estaba creciendo
mucho apóstol siempre fue chamba se
dedicó al espárrago a la falta del
arándano y el sueño de apóstol era poder
darle a sus hijos una mejor vida de la
que él tuvo era poder ver a sus tres
hijos profesionales para eso trabaja
apóstol no obstante él necesitaba de
incentivos en este largo camino para no
desanimarse necesitabas saber que estaba
en la dirección correcta que la estaba
haciendo es por eso que apóstol usaba el
consumo como una forma de traer with
wings rápido reconocimientos a casa
así en cada campaña el invertir su
dinero en un aparato electrónico o en un
electrodoméstico para su familia así lo
demostraba a los suyos que podía darle
una vida mejor pero no sólo eso
que los miraba que los cuidaba y que él
cumplía como un buen proveedor
muchas personas me preguntan por qué la
base de la pirámide tiene televisores
tan grandes y sus casas aún no están
terminadas como se ve es un problema en
el orden de prioridades
y quiero ser muy enfática en esta
afirmación y es que la evidencia nos
muestra que la base de la pirámide si
tiene muy claras prioridades
cuando apóstol trajo ese televisor de
plasma a casa trabajo mucho más que una
forma de entretenerse trajo una forma de
mantener seguros a sus hijos dentro de
la casa lejos de los peligros de la
calle tras una forma de informarse una
forma de compartir en familia y hoy en
el momento actual una forma de educarse
basta escucharlos para entender que el
significado dado a ciertos objetos es de
gran complejidad y su función es un
motivo de estar allí tiene un propósito
el caso y las historias de apóstol y
tantas otras historias de colaboradores
agrícolas inspiró a ortiz a crear un
sistema de fidelización basado en puntos
de apóstol no faltaba nunca su chamba
cumplía con ser un colega solidario y
además recogía mucha fruta ganaba puntos
esos puntos podrían ser canjeados por
refrigeradoras cocinillas colchones
televisores entre otras cosas de esta
forma
hortyfruta ayudaba a boston a llevar
estos quick wins estos rápidos
reconocimientos a casa y que el dinero
de la cosecha pudiese ser nuevamente
direccionado a lo que para apóstol era
lo más importante que es la educación de
sus hijos
hortyfruta también ganó porque sus
colaboradores se quedaron con ellos
durante toda la campaña y hoy hortifrut
es la primera elección de apóstol todos
los años
se dan cuenta que simplemente escuchando
a la base de la pirámide conectando con
sus dolores y sus necesidades somos
capaces primero de romper con muchos de
los prejuicios que cargamos
que podemos desde nuestros negocios
generar eficiencias y rentabilidades en
los socios que ellos necesitan para
impulsar su desarrollo
al representar
el 87 por ciento de la población de
alguna u otra forma todos estamos
conectados con la base de la pirámide ya
sea porque son parte de la base de la
pirámide ya sea porque tenemos
colaboradores que son parte de la base
de la pirámide porque tenemos
consumidores distribuidores o
proveedores que son parte de la base de
la pirámide
si la base es la mayoría del perú
no sería hoy durante la pandemia un
momento de crisis pero que empuja
cambios el momento ideal para poder
generar valor a esta base
no queremos acaso que la mayoría de perú
prospere
no queremos generar ingresos sí pero
también generar inclusión
no queremos una sociedad más justa más
equitativa y con más oportunidades para
todos y para todas
yo me imagino que sí que si es posible
construir un futuro diferente entonces
desde donde estemos hagamos lo posible
muchas gracias